All right.
Um all right. Welcome to the DDPS
seminar, everyone. Before we introduce
our invited speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First of all,
please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions. If you have
questions,
you're welcome to unmute and ask.
Otherwise, please use
chat room to post your questions so that
we can address them in Q&A session at
the end.
Second, today's DDPS seminar is open to
external audiences. Therefore, no
classified discussion is allowed.
Please watch out. Finally, the talk
today will be recorded and uploaded
in our YouTube channel. That's about it.
Now, let me introduce our speaker today.
It is an honor to host Sergei uh
Tretiak, uh who is a T-1 deputy group
leader in the theoretical division of
division at Los Alamos National Lab.
And Los Alamos National Lab fellow.
He received his master's degree in
physics in 1994 from Moscow Institute of
Physics and Technology.
And his chemistry doctorate in 1998 from
the University of Rochester.
He was then a director-funded
postdoctoral fellow uh from 1999
to 2001 and subsequently became a staff
scientist at uh Los Alamos National Lab.
And a member of the DOE-funded center
for integrated nanotechnology
technologies.
Uh Sergei also um
deserves as an adjunct professor at the
University of California, Santa Barbara
from 2015 to present.
And at Skolkovo Institute of Science and
Technology
uh in Russia from 2013 to present. He
became an American Physical Society
Fellow in 2014 and a Fellow of the Royal
Society of Chemistry in 2019.
He has also received a Humboldt Research
Award in 2021,
the Los Alamos Postdoctoral
Distinguished Mentor Award in 2015,
and the Los Alamos Fellow Prize for
research in 2010.
His research interests include
development of electronic structure
methods for molecular optical
properties, nonlinear optical response
of organic chromophores,
non-adiabatic
the dynamics of electronically excited
states, optical response of confined ex-
excitons in con-
conjugated polymers, carbon nanotubes,
semiconductor nanoparticles, mixed
halide
perov- perovskite,
and molecular aggregates. The use of
machine learning and data science toward
modeling electronic and chemical
properties.
Serge has published more than 300
scientific publications, cited more than
20,000 times,
and he has presented more than 300
invited and keynote talks in the US and
abroad. Today, Serge will give a talk
with the title of machine learning for
materials and
chemical dynamics. Please expect a
wonderful talk from him and enjoy it, of
course.
Now, without further ado, let me pass
the button to Serge by asking one random
questions. The question is, what is your
favorite things to do other than
research?
Well, other than research, remember that
I'm living in Los Alamos in New Mexico.
And New Mexico is a land of enchantment.
And there are three favorite things for
one
to do in the northern New Mexico, which
is
biking,
I'm a mountain biker,
skiing, downhill skiing, and hiking. So,
those are three favorite things that I
like to do.
That sounds
very good. I mean, and sounds very
healthy. So,
I guess it's good for you.
I can name a fourth thing.
And actually,
uh
my mentor, Jean-Luc Brédas, he is a big
professor in uh Arizona. And at one
point, he visited Los Alamos and
um
he looked at me and said, "Well, why
don't you do the real chemistry?"
Because I'm a theoretical chemist. And
then, uh since then, I started brewing
beer. So, that's a real experimental
chemistry, and it's fascinating to do.
Every day you do it?
No, no, no, no, no, no. Of course not.
Not every day.
All right. Sounds good. The stage is
yours.
Yep. Thank you so much, Yansu, for a
kind introduction. And it's an honor to
present a
DDPS seminar. And uh let me start with
introducing
uh some research topics that I would be
happy to discuss offline that typically
my team is interested in. So, for many,
many I'm a theoretical chemist, as I
mentioned. And for many, many years, we
have been
looking at the dynamics of excited
states.
When you initiate joint electron phonon
dynamics, and you have a fascinating
evolution of the wave function, as you
could see on those movies. And in this
evolution, the electronic energy
migrates to
ionic degrees of freedom and back.
And as a result of this dynamics, you
could describe those phenomena such as
energy and charge transfer. And then,
you could build something like uh
effective model for description of
uh energy and just charge transfer.
As Youngsoo was saying that I'm a member
of CINT, Center for Integrated
Nanotechnologies, and there we are
looking at various nano systems. For
example,
as you know that quantum materials have
been latest push toward exciting
technologies. And we have been looking
at
functionalized carbon nanotubes, where
the chemical group is attached to the
surface of the nanotube, and this makes
them a quantum emitters. So that those
nanotubes can emit
very pure light. A similar development
has been going on in the land of
quantum dots, where the semiconductor
nanocrystal
becomes a quantum emitter, which is
possible to use for example for quantum
information transduction, or just to
making
optical quantum computer.
And of course, perovskite materials have
been a recent newcomers as a functional
materials used for a number of
technologies. I will name a few such as
photovoltaics, lightning,
um
In In Los Alamos, we have been
particularly interested in using
perovskite materials for detection
purposes, such as gamma ray and x-ray
detectors.
And of course, over the past 5 years, we
have been very interested in pushing the
methodology forward by invoking data
science and machine learning, and this
part would be a subject of my today's
talk.
Uh this is my plan for today. So first
of all, I will briefly introduce to
machine learning approaches and their
challenges as you apply them to chemical
and material systems.
Then I will skip perhaps like a decade
of development all over the world and
talk about
some recent development and in
particular answer the question how do
you make a database from which you are
learning.
So I'll talk about active learning
strategy on an example of aluminum force
fields.
Then I will
uh
introduce into a major drawback of the
current machine learning framework which
is
locality.
And then I'll outline some recipes how
we can potentially overcome this
uh fundamental locality limit and
describe non-local effects for charged
systems such as anions and cations
and for excited states.
So let's go ahead along this plan and
essentially
I'm not going to introduce you in
machine learning and the famous example
is how you examine the photograph and
pixelated image and come up with the
input of a dog and in the course of my
uh presentation I will be solely focused
on the
neural networks, more specifically
convolutional
neural networks where you are parsing
the information through the layers of
the networks and at the end of the day
you have something chemical on this side
and then you are trying to assign a
label which would be a desired property
on that side.
So let me just introduce to you a big
picture.
A chemist perspective on the material
science.
You start with atoms
then you make a bonds, come up with
molecules, nanoparticles, 2D 3D
structures and much larger systems such
as polymers and biological systems.
So that you could see that there is a
clear distinction between local
properties
such as
bonds, energy, charge, atomic charges,
and global properties. What is the total
energy of your systems?
What would be excited states? What How
the electronic density is distributed?
What is spectroscopic properties? How
you could
manage energy and charge transport in
this and those systems?
So that's where the machine learning can
come handy when you're going across the
array of materials.
And then the question is, can we
outsmart conventional quantum chemistry?
Will artificial intelligence or ML be an
answer
for cutting the corners?
And most importantly, what would be the
technical ways to address the
observables such as energies,
dynamical propagation, parameters,
Hamiltonians, and so on.
So
again, sort of like to introduce you to
the land of theoretical chemistry, there
is a speed versus accuracy gap.
If you're trying to solve the quantum
equation such as Schrödinger equation,
then the exact solution will cost you an
exponential expense with respect to the
system size.
When you go down and apply some
approximation and DFT is one popular
in quotes first principle approximation,
of course you could just
downscale
your expense to maybe like n in the
power of three.
On this
on this side, there is a classical force
field.
Where you forgot the quantum mechanics
and use the
simple model when you have bonds on the
springs.
However, in this key on this side the
error is large and on this side is the
error is small and what we would like to
achieve with machine learning is
to embrace both sides.
To cut the corner.
So now
let's talk about a simple example.
Molecular dynamics.
To
do the classical molecular dynamics,
let's say in the Born-Oppenheimer
regime, you need to solve the Newtonian
equation of motion
where the main thing would be the
gradients.
The forces acting on a particular atom.
You can get those gradients as a
derivatives of course of the energy and
the energy you could get from the
solution of the Schrödinger equation.
That's where the expense for quantum
mechanical simulations is coming into
the picture.
So now we are asking, so in principle,
how can we bypass the quantum mechanical
simulations?
And one way to bypass it would be the
classical force field which enable
millions of atoms of simulations
versus hundreds of atoms
if you are using the quantum force field
in the land of so-called
ab initio molecular dynamics.
So again, so to like we are trying to
utilize machine learning and in
particular I'll be talking about
supervised machine learning when we have
a set of inputs
and the set of variables, we are
learning the unknown functions
and we are training this unknown
function to the prescribed data set.
And once the how we are getting to those
data sets would be a major subject of my
talk. And of course the supervised
machine learning has been used for
multiple tasks such as regression and
classification. Many application I
already showed you the image recognition
and there are multiple example of
algorithms.
So, just to test this in the context of
chemistry,
our structure would define as a
descriptors.
Whereas the properties would be defined
as a labels.
Again, so we are passing this through
the neural network. And of course, we
would like to train so that our neural
network will perform accurately. So,
prediction versus reference benchmark.
And then we are using those neural
networks to simulate some desired
physical properties such as spectra.
Okay?
So, but what is
most missing in this picture? That would
be so-called extensibility
and transferability tests, which are
extremely important.
So, as a
extensibility means that if you are
training on the data set that is
generated for small system, let's say
for small molecules,
you're asking the question how well your
neural networks will perform for much
larger system, for much larger molecules
such as proteins.
And the second question is about
transferability.
For a chemist, I would say, "What if you
are training your neural network for one
molecular family such as non-aromatic
compound? And you would like to transfer
your neural network to
perform for aromatic compounds, which
are very different systems?"
Will you get any useful results?
Of course, this is a big question to
answer. And answering to these
questions,
to some extent, is extremely important
before you start jumping into uh
simulations of the properties.
Again, so to this is another picture
just to show in the big picture that we
need to establish the relationship
between structure and properties. And
now let's go into the um
specific
recipes how one can we can do that.
So, typically once you start uh the
applying the neural network in
chemistry, you entertain the idea of
locality.
Let me have uh this simple equation that
you have a property
and it could be anything. For example,
like total energy of your system.
And then you are presenting this
property as a sum of the individual
energies of your atoms.
Okay? And this underpins the idea of
locality.
And then how you can do that? You
entertain concept of effective atoms in
the specific chemical environment. So,
this is a molecule. You associate
with each nuclear center some effective
atoms, taking into account the effect of
immediate chemical environment subject
to a certain cutoff.
The certain cutoff would be on the order
of about five angstroms.
And why five angstroms?
The answer is that you need to go beyond
the length of the typical chemical
bonds.
Remember that we are talking about
chemistry and chemists are saying that
the old chemistry is
local.
Okay, so now uh
Then I will go beyond this
thing and then discuss two specific
properties.
Two specific things. One is how we can
construct a proper training set
by embracing both chemical space,
chemical space means that if you change
one molecule to another one,
and conformational space.
And conformational space means that if
you are making dynamics on the molecule
and and molecule goes through some kind
of reaction barrier, which
sort of like entails the uh
change of the structure.
And then the final cha- challenge would
be how we can
overcome the locality approximation.
The central idea in the building the
neural networks.
So,
the fundamental idea came from the
seminal work of Behler and Parrinello.
They were first to construct this neural
network when they said that the energy
of the system would be a sum of the
energies of individual atoms.
And each individual atom is described by
its specific uh neural network that is
trained.
And
remember that I showed you a picture of
the photograph of the of the dog. So,
similar like you pixelate the picture,
you describe the atom with atomic
environment vector.
And this atomic environment vector will
usually uh include radial description
and angular description. So, the radial
description means that it gives you an
information what are the atoms in the
neighborhood.
And angular description gives uh what
are the angles. And of course, uh the
angle give you some kind of uh implicit
information about chemical bonding for a
given atom.
So, this was the original Behler and
Parrinello
uh neural network and
after that, there have been
almost two decades of uh development,
maybe 15 years.
And during that, those neural networks
have been complicated a lot. And in Los
Alamos, we have been
helping to develop and improve several
types of neural networks, which are
essentially some adapted versions like
what is published by the big companies
such as Google like TensorFlow and so
forth.
So, the first one would be any family
which is a modified Baylor approach. The
second one would be Hip and N family
which was developed by uh Kipton Barros
and Nick Lubbers at Los Alamos.
And the main feature would be
interacting layers. And the third one
would be AMNet by Olusola
which features a self-consistent
So, any family was developed by
originally by Justin Smith and Adrian
Roitberg. And Justin was a postdoc at
Los Alamos and now he's happily working
at Nvidia. So, we are suffering from
this sucking up the talent from uh
national labs, universities to the uh
industrial companies.
So, anyway, I will uh talk a little bit
about those ones and just I'll give you
the some big pictures by saying this was
the original
um
Baylor and Perinola. And this type is uh
Hip and N and this one would be AMNet.
So, you could see there are lots of
things that is going on inside of the
neural networks. And I will describe in
my talk some of those things.
Okay, now. First of all, let's talk
about databases because if you are
going on the land of machine learning,
the databases make a critical difference
for the quality of your product.
So, and surprisingly,
we have been using so-called ensemble
disagreement.
But, it's very simple approach which is
showing you where on the face space you
have
uh lack of training.
So, let's imagine that instead of a
single neural network, you are training
several neural networks.
And then you run the dynamics in
parallel across those neural networks
and see whether the answers are agreeing
to each other.
And in general, if the answers do agree,
then we conclude that the
neural networks had adequate training,
and this phase space is covered. If the
answers disagree, then perhaps we need
to add more points.
So, this general principle serves for
uncertainty quantification, which is
critical for training, and also it
underpins the active learning approach,
which is helping to automate this
process.
So, what it means is that just imagine
that you have, let's say, the CPU
cluster and GPU cluster. GPU is running
neural net dynamics, and CPU is doing
reference quantum mechanical
simulations.
So, the neural nets, after several
cycles, are asking CPU to produce more
data,
and CPU is producing more data. There is
a retraining of the neural nets, more
dynamics, and the new data is requested.
In fact, sort of like you can just go
away, and in a week
time you could come back and gather your
hopefully improved neural nets.
Okay?
So, and again, sort of like the active
learning is allowing us to under-cap
and optimally choose the data sets.
So, just this approach is This is t-SNE
plots for several data sets.
QM9,
we are starting from molecular systems.
QM9 is a data set of the small
molecules, which are in the
in the ground state.
Anyone
would be those molecules
which are stretched along the
confirmation. So, that's a dynamically
induced
data set which was obtained by
stretching along the normal mode. So,
here we have
50 K of species. Here we have 20
millions of species.
And now if you are using as the active
learning, then 20 millions can
be reduced to
about 5 millions so that without any
uh
negative effect to the quality of the
training set. And then one could just
analyze those Disney plots and uh see
some type of
typical chemical bond bonds that you
could see in those molecular systems.
That's a principle
for active learning.
And in particular, active learning
becomes
very important when you're trying to
transfer from low-fidelity methods to
the high-fidelity methods.
And that could be sort of like I'm not
going to talk about this one, but it is
possible to do. And then you need to use
active learning here and there.
So, let's talk about Livermore.
We were happy enough to occupy Sierra
for a couple of months before it went to
the production. And as you know, so
you're hosting Sierra
and this is a number one on the top 500
list.
Or number two on the top 500 list. Yes.
So, we have been using Sierra and
occupying almost the whole thing by
trying to develop the aluminum
interatomic potentials.
Namely, what we have been doing, we have
been starting from melt.
Namely, a random arrangement of the
aluminum atoms in the periodic cell.
So that the density functional theory
has been calculated those.
And of course you need to just to throw
away some unphysical arrangement. For
example, when the atoms are way too
close to each other those are would be
unphysical.
So that
this way
you start with a principle that you
don't know anything about the system.
And you would like to learn not only the
non-equilibrium dynamics, but also you
would like to learn the
equilibrium confirmations.
So at the end of the day once you
accomplish this active learning
cycles, many cycles
so that it was done was done completely
automatically without human
interventions.
Sort of like hands-free approach, and
then you start
seeing and visualizing what is going on
then you could uh
sort of like identify what are the
preferred crystalline stable crystals.
What would be the liquid phase? What
would be the shock configuration and
highly disordered configuration?
Okay, so that's a principle. And then of
course at the end of the day
you take those data, you take those
interatomic potential which would be the
machine learned force field
and you conduct massive molecular
dynamics
on your laptop.
Because you are now down to the uh
linear cost of
uh simulations. And this has been done
on the laptop.
And uh at the end of the day sort of
um
you have this uh shock formations. And
uh this is about 1.3 millions of
uh aluminum atoms
uh simulations.
So now
that's how you gather the data.
What
would be the future approach for
gathering the data?
How do we sample the phase space where
we want? This is learning of unknown.
Think about catalytic reactions.
Frequently when we are talking about
catalysis
and I'm really happy to see that now we
are pushing toward green energies, to
the toward the hydrogen economy.
And when we are talking about catalysis,
it's all about learning what kind of
what is happening into the energy
barriers.
And frequently we don't know where those
energy barriers are. And the question
is, how one can pinpoint
and learn adequately from the energy for
the energy barriers.
And here we have been recently
developing two ideas. One was the active
learning combined with the transition
path sampler.
So, you have reactants and you have
products.
And you could use something like an
artificial elastic band to pinpoint one
path through the barrier, and then you
use active learning
to sort of like sample the phase space
around the barrier
to learn a force field to describe some
kind of catalytic reactions.
And the second would be a biased
dynamics where your uncertainty will
push you toward unknown phase space.
Those would be an important improvement
on the land of
machine learning.
Okay, so let me move on and address the
second topic of my talk.
It's how to overcome the locality
challenge.
Now, let's talk about first about charge
systems.
When I'm talking to to my data science
colleague, I was challenged.
So, um for example, I'm asking the
question, what if you have a bucket of
material and I drop a single electron
there?
Where would this electron end up?
In which corner? And how delocalized
this electron would be?
Even at the level of a simple molecule,
when I'm dropping the electron,
whether the electron would end up on the
right side or on the left side.
And maybe if when you start rotating
around the bond which is in the middle,
at some point the delocalization of the
electron will change and the electron
would be delocalized completely over the
molecule.
So, again, sort of like those are
important questions when they are
developing green energy technology or um
some uh electrochemistry.
Ionization potential, that's the energy
to take uh away the electron or electron
affinity, the energy to add the
electron, uh sort of kind of main
properties.
For quantum chemistry, we are usually
using DFT flavors. In experiment, you're
using cyclic voltammetry.
Now, if you would like to start learning
about electronic properties, then you
need to
discretize the electronic density.
Remember that the electrons are making a
cloud around the molecule. So, this is a
molecule, that's your electronic
density, which forms electrostatic
potential, which is relevant to all
those charge states.
Now, you would like to discretize this
density and you would like to assign the
point charge to every atom. And remember
those point charges underpin virtually
all uh classical force fields.
But there is no charge partitioning
schemes and those those uh things are
ill-conditioned. Again, I can go in
depth into this uh question, but for
now, let's think about that let's say
that one need to be take care about this
partitioning in particular.
So, now,
here we have been using aim eight atoms
in molecule molecules.
And with this approach, we were able to
overcome the locality approximation.
And the locality is approximation is
overcome by two important improvements.
Number one,
usually like in any type of balance and
vanilla type of things, we are starting
with atomic environment
and end up with energy.
So here, there is a feedback loop
to the atomic feature environment,
which is updated several times.
Think about it as a
mean field loop or self-consistent loop
that you are using some somewhere like
in Hartree-Fock theory or density
functional theory. However, in this
case, there is no variational principle
and there is no guarantee that it will
ever converge, but as a result,
after two or three iterations, you are
improving your answer quite a bit,
particularly for non-locality things.
When you remember this non-locality,
when the electron is not so to like
ending up on the atoms, but they
becoming local the localized somewhere
else.
And the second thing is to introduce the
atomic weight factors.
Underpinning the idea of neutral spin
equilibration.
Those atomic weight factors are in fact
can be associated to the weight how this
particular atom is participating in this
delocalization.
Okay? So and then we apply this thing
and try to
learn the distribution of the charges on
the molecule. This is
our aim molecule
beyond the data set that has been
trained.
Now we have anionic species and cationic
species.
That's how your spin density is
delocalized. Of course, when we have a
cations, then the electron is
delocalizing and here is a hole is
delocalizing.
Now, this would be your um individual
charges with color which are color
coded.
And this would be your so-called NBO
charge partition partitioning scheme.
I won't go into the details, but this
would be my reference DFT data to which
I'm comparing to.
Okay? So, these guys. And now, when I'm
starting from an anion and cation, the
original neural network does not know
about non-locality and distribution of
the charge. But once you start doing the
self-consistent loop with the weight
factors, at the end of the day, you're
learning them properly.
So, that you do a a various test
extensive
and sensitivity and transferability.
But
and you get approximately 4 kcal per
mole accuracy for ionization potential
and electron affinity.
And in fact, if you start comparing your
reference ground truth or DFT simulation
to even better ground truth, which would
be an experiment, then the difference
would be on the order of 10 to 20 kcal
per mole.
So, which means that
machine learning is already able to
overcome the DFT error bar.
So, now, once you do that, you would
like to do some applications. You could
apply the conceptual DFT, which deals
with electronegativity, with chemical
hardness, electrophilicity, Fukui
indices. And just one thing, so for
example, one could just look at the
electrophilic uh,
And those are electrophilic reactions
uh, frequently underpin the drug
development and many industrial
companies are interested in this.
And in fact, one could do a quantum
mechanical free regioselectivity
prediction for the data sets which were
not originally in the training set for
the machine learning.
And in fact, those predictions are on
par with the best
predictions of models that have been
using at least partially the quantum
mechanics.
So, this is sounds very uh, encouraging
for the success of machine learning in
such complicated phenomena where you
always have
delocalized uh, charge dynamics which
involves some region of space which is
impossible to describe with the usual
local approximation in the machine
learning.
So, finally, let me briefly talk about
triplet states which would be an excited
state. This would be your singlet state
potential energy surface and triplet
state. And triplet state, for example,
are responsible for
phosphorescence.
Triplet states are becoming uh,
important for so-called TADF, thermally
activated delayed fluorescence, when
they serve as uh,
storage
for energy and then you could extract
the storage and use it for the light
emission. But it's what is most
important is to describe those
transition energies, singlet to triplet
state transition, and triplet back to
the singlet from its equilibrium
geometry.
And of course, you could just describe
this in terms of the regions of
conformational space
which are relevant to those geometries
and um
you start learning again on the example
of small molecules,
and it's not surprising that you have
your accuracy for your data set, for
your validation data set, on the order
of a couple kcal per mole.
So far, it's not surprising. It is
expected because you are learning
uh some uh features of the potential
energy surface.
So now,
in a moment, I would like to do the
transferability, and the transferability
will fail if you are using the normal
locality bound networks.
So that we need again to go beyond the
transferability.
And here we are using so-called Hip-NN
model,
and there are again two features in the
Hip-NN model which allow you to go
beyond the transferability.
The one feature would be those green
bars.
Those green bars are interaction layers,
and they describe interaction between
atoms.
For physicists, I can make an analogy of
those green bars to the many-body
perturbation theory,
like the second order, third order, and
so forth.
So this way, we are
making the machine learning aware that
there is something else beyond this
limitation sphere of the radius of five
angstroms.
The second important thing would be
again
assignment of the weights.
So that
you have those local energies, and
you're assigning the weight to those
local energies, which is a learnable a
quality.
So that we'll come to the physical
interpretation of those weights in a
moment.
But in fact that we are learning those
weights and this is a participation of a
given pattern
in the excited states.
And remember that our excited states are
always delocalized.
Which precludes the using of the locally
bound approaches.
So now
when I have been talking about
transferability, this is what I mean.
This is our training set.
Training sets are always some small
molecules up to like 15 non-hydrogen
atoms.
And most of the molecules are
non-aromatic.
If you are talking about practical
application of the triplet states, then
we are talking about
phosphorescence and mostly aromatic
compounds.
Which has many benzene rings fused
together. So that the aromaticity extend
over the large length scales. And in
fact sort of like we have this
aromatic compounds.
Where non-locality effects would be
extremely important.
So now
remember that test set was small
molecules.
Extensibility test was large molecules.
Non-aromatic molecules. And if you will
use the usual HIP and N where the
locality effects are pronounced, then
you won't get any good result as
expected for aromatic compounds.
But if you are using HIP and N lock
where you using those weights
then the results improve
even though we don't have particularly
good
accuracy. And our accuracy is 10 K K cal
per mole versus reference DFT. And I
remind you that the reference DFT
usually versus experiment has a
of the same order of error.
So, still the going over non-locality
effects is extremely important.
Now, let's talk about those weights.
And in fact,
those weights are reflecting the
distribution of the spin density over
atoms.
So, in the simplistic jargon,
we haven't doing been doing the quantum
mechanics.
We have been operating just with
energies that is coming from the quantum
mechanics.
However, the machine learning was able
to infer
where the density is and where the
special distribution of the wave
function would be.
So, just enjoy those movies.
This is reference DFT and this is a
chip log. And you could see there is not
exact, but approximate
approximate consistency between those
representation.
So, what it means
to us is that the distribution of the
wave function is an important parameter
to learn in the future.
But this is fantastic. So, I change the
geometry of the molecule
and my machine learning is able to sort
of like to predict to some extent the
evolution of the charge distribution and
the evolution of the
um
wave function on the
over a particular excitation on the
molecule.
So, and where is the future?
In the previous slides, I tried to
demonstrate you that coordinates and
velocities of particles are not enough
to describe the dynamics.
Think about it. You dissociate the
water. In one case, you have charged
species and in another case, you have
radicals.
So that those species cannot be
described by the coordinates and
velocity and you need the auxiliary
variables. You need to build the ML
models which are electron aware.
If I will talking about shock
distribution, which is dear to the heart
uh at uh Livermore as well,
then the shock distribution has other
parameters such as for example like
temperature.
And temperature can play this role of
electron aware auxiliary variable.
So that the simulation history and
memory effects are extremely important
and introducing
immediate direct flavors of quantum
mechanics in the learning such as
polarization, charge distribution would
be very important for the development of
future machine learning models. And one
example would be charge equilibration
models when you explicitly take into
account the charges and equilibrate them
in ML.
Okay, so this brings me to about 45
minutes of my talk and let me conclude
that overall in the land of chemistry
and material science, ML and AI
approaches are here to stay.
And altogether, machine learning is not
an automatic procedure.
In fact,
it is very hard to find qualified people
to doing this work.
Because the person need to understand
the physical background and in parallel
have a good understanding of the data
side.
The approach to your results from
machine learning as a black box frame.
Have some healthy skepticism when you
are trying to interpret the results.
Uh to me
and this term goes back to Misha
Chertkov who
taught me this about 10 years ago.
Physics inform machine learning. One
needs to build as much physical
intuition into the machine learning and
I try to demonstrate these examples of
like introducing the weight for a
particular atoms which reflect the
distribution of the wave function.
Solving specific problem is the next
frontier for ML.
There have been way too many
demonstration of proof of principle but
what if we'll take some experimental
problem and try to do the ML to solve
this experimental problem. And in
particular one important thing is how we
can fuse the data. Fuse the data that
are coming from quantum chemistry,
quantum mechanics and those data that
are coming from experiment.
And those data frequently very have very
different nature and different error
bars.
And finally sort of like um
common standards and user-friendly
machine learning codes are
coming and hopefully in a few years
we'll be able to take something like
Gaussian or VASP from the shelf and do
the simulations using building the
machine learning and some molecular
dynamics codes like Sandia's, LAMMPS
have already extensive sets of machine
learning models and extensive set of an
interatomic potentials there.
Again, sort of like
Look at this. So now we could just say
that the
reactive chemistry is possible to
describe with machine learning
frameworks. You could see that this uh
hydrogen will migrate. This is a
reaction, chemical reaction.
One could describe uh reactive
chemistry, for example, the growth of
nanoparticles. This is a uh uh growth of
the carbon structure out of the hot
carbon mixed at uh like couple of
thousand temperature.
So, you can uh you have a very strong uh
uh reactive dynamics there.
This is already possible to do with
machine learning. So, you could see
growth of uh fullerenes or graphenes
there.
And again, sort of like uh
Center for Integrated Nanotechnology
Great User uh
User Facility.
You're welcome to be our users. And um
Los Alamos had a very strong program uh
for students and postdocs. And finally,
I need to uh acknowledge many, many
people participating in this work. There
is a team at Los Alamos working on
machine learning, Keeton Barros, Ben
Nadybal. Justin Smith is now at Nvidia.
Anders Nikolaev,
uh Galen Craven, Malcolm Malone assumed
a faculty position. Nick Lubbers, Yin
Vallely. And every time we have about 10
summer students. We have very close
collaboration with experiment, for
example, like how can we can describe
the shock physics, how can we describe
the self-assembly of materials, and
external collaborators such as Oleg
Sysuev and Daniel Rorvik.
So, with that, let me thank for your
kind attention, and I'm happy to answer
any questions.
Thank you. Thank you so much for the
wonderful talk. Um it was very
informative, and I learned a lot. Um
So, okay, as Sergey said, let's have a
Q&A sessions. Um if you have questions,
please
unmute yourself, maybe, uh or yeah, um
So,
the first question
comes up in the chat room, uh
Shau-Wu Ting,
uh
asked that can you comment on the how
many data points are needed to start the
active learning process?
Okay, so let's go back to the active
learning.
Yeah.
So, the answer is it depends.
So, if you look at the different machine
learning models,
particularly if you are using neural
networks, those neural networks
frequently have about uh
10 100
uh 10
100,000 of parameters.
So, it's uh
many many parameters. With those
parameters, you could fit everything, so
that
um
overfitting is becoming a real problem.
So, that to start the active learning
procedure, you need just to learn to
something.
For example, uh on the land of
um
say, so let me go back to
this. Okay,
sure.
So, here,
you uh try to use anyone basis basis
set.
You start with learning about uh
you have 5 million data points in this
data data set.
Perhaps, you could start with uh like
10,000
of data points, and then augment those
10,000 to
um maybe 200,000 to 500,000
using the active learning.
Thank you. Thank you for the comment.
Yeah, so if you
Yes, uh like not yet there. So, if you
are using
something like couple cluster. If you
are using DFT, then you need to augment
it by a factor of 10 everything.
If you are using for example like
periodic boundary conditions for the
aluminum, you could start with 1,000
data points. Just
Active learning should be intimately
bound to the number of parameters that
you are optimizing in your neural
network.
How how about I because
I'm actually facing thinking about
applying active learning in an
experimental
to guide experiment in with um 3D
printing
here at Livermore in a project. So, I'm
actually thinking about like simpler
models like Gaussian process. Do you
have any experience with like yeah,
active learning with experiment data
which is like way way less than the
DFT and simulation data. Any comments
about
this?
Absolutely. Absolutely. So, remember
here I'm talking about quantum chemistry
and quantum chemistry is producing a lot
of data.
And we have a lot of parameters in the
neural network.
You mentioned the keyword which is
Gaussian regression. The Gaussian
regression is
um
has much less parameters. So, you could
get away with much smaller points if you
are trying to fit and guide the
experiment.
So, a better question that we have to
that
should be answered right now is
how to guide the experiment not only
based on experimental data
which would belong to the sort of like
uh
the land of robotic labs or the land of
materials informatics, but also to add
some descriptors which are coming from
molecular model.
I guess
much better guidance can be obtained in
this case.
If for example, you will introduce
some constraint.
And
I just saw in the chat that domain
informed machine learning.
So, this would be a typical jargon that
you could use
for this research.
Okay.
Thank you for the comments.
Okay, so
the next
the following question is about the
domain informed ML for this case.
How does one choose the best base space
for a given category in molecular
modeling for chemistry?
Well, sort of
again um
It depends on
the
on the chemical and conformational
space.
And there could be different strategies.
What do you want to learn?
Let's say sort of you want to learn the
uh
interatomic potentials for
um
not strongly non-equilibrium when near
equilibrium dynamics.
Then you could make you may start with
the data points for active learning
which are close to the equilibrium data
points.
And then expand them to the
non-equilibrium regime.
If you are learning to the
strongly non-equilibrium dynamics such
as shock physics such as reactive
chemistry.
Then
you need to push your active learning in
those other regions.
So, our example of
um aluminum type of
interatomic potential is where we
started from complete mass.
Which was overkill. And we had the like
hands-free machine learning only because
we had Sierra to our disposal.
But if you look at the development of
interatomic potentials, even when people
have been using the active learning,
then people usually have been starting
from the crystal phases and augmented
the phase space to non-equilibrium
conditions.
Again, domain formal knowledge is a
keyword.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right. Uh the next question is from
James. Do you see the future of ML
in the interatomic potential field being
more geared towards mapping structural
and chemical
information directly to a black box
function or more towards using ML to
learn parameter sets for more
physics-informed functional forms such
as the EAM?
Well,
those are two different schools of
thought.
Uh again, sort of like if I would like
to do the
in quotes classical molecular dynamics
by propagating Newtonian equation of
motion,
then in one school of thought I may say
that I will use the black box type of
approach
and train machine neural nets to this
in a black box type of fashion, which
are really hard to interpret.
And one needs just to go across
extensibility transferability test.
The advantage is is that
um perhaps this black box would be a
little bit more flexible.
And automatically will account for
unknown uh phase space where perhaps
some physical
um
domain like knowledge will uh
guide
the learning.
But again, so to like the drawback, it's
still the black box.
On the other hand, you could just take
from off-shelf some kind of
uh classical force fields and you use
machine learning to
re-parameterize those force fields.
This is also valid and we have been
doing this by trying to re-parameterize,
for example, like um
the dihedral angles based on the density
functional theory.
This way, you will retain your physical
picture like very clear description in
terms of like bonds and the springs.
But
this physical picture, it has a limited
application to non-equilibrium
conditions.
So, I guess both will have uh
some existence in the future
and both will be augmented with some
auxiliary variables. And it has been
already done, for example, in the length
of the polarizable force fields.
Again, it's very hard to say
what will win, but for sure, the current
classical force fields that we are using
right now will be displaced with force
fields which will have some machine
learning flavor.
Okay. Um the next question is from
Andre.
Uh Sergey, the performance of NN is
strongly dependent on its structure, uh
for example, number of layers, etc.
Same is true for the Gaussian process
uh regression. And has any work done on
optimizing the NN GP uh for given data
sets in the applications you considered.
It's a very difficult question.
And it's a there is no yes or no answer
to this question.
And frequently all this knowledge is
quite empirical.
Just I will add
to this knowledge, for example,
one empirical parameter would be the
cutoff radius.
Now, the another empirical parameter is
how many
layers neural network layers you will
put there.
And if, for example, we have been
entertaining this for a while, and at
some point we wanted to do the transfer
learning.
We wanted to train the neural networks
to DFT data and transfer learn to couple
cluster data.
So, perhaps I can just show you some of
the pictures.
Yeah, perhaps you could look at those
things and
um the original neural network that we
have been using for DFT had about
300,000 parameters
in the neural networks.
And we are able to avoid over fitting by
calculating 5 million points. Now, for
the couple cluster data, we were able to
calculate only 500 points.
And the number of parameters would be
way too many to avoid over fitting. And
then sort of like Justin has been fixing
some of the parameters,
except
letting some parameter go. Now, what
would be the parameters where you will
let go in the middle of the neural nets
or at the end of the neural nets?
And the
fitting procedure was very different.
And the results were very different for
the middle uh
or the last layer
uh parameters.
So, again, sort of like
while people are making progress to
interpretability and to a rational
design of something like neural
networks, but most of the current work
to me has been done on the
empirical basis
or where people are sort of um
refer to the previous experience and to
other works.
There is no clear um
algorithm.
Yeah. Sergey, there there is a um
algorithm development on the
neural architecture search, so-called
NAS, and the Argonne National Lab is
doing
Yeah.
Um
So, the NAS is one of those efforts that
just uh is trying to put some sanity
into the multitude of the neural
networks that is existing in Europe, in
the US, etc.
Yeah. Yeah. So, that might that might
help. Of course, I mean, when you say
physics-informed
um
uh you mean by um you know, taking
taking account you know, existing
physics knowledge and
and and then design the neural net
accordingly, right? And so, that's
Yeah, there are sort of like there are
different schools of thought about it.
Yeah.
Well, I personally like physics-informed
learning, and I personally like to
incorporate like chemistry intuition
from a
uh chemist who is saying, "This will
work, and this will not."
Some people could argue that we need to
get rid of it and to apply the approach
that we have been doing for aluminum
without any presumption and perhaps the
ML will infer some unknown
pathways or unknown phase space regions
which goes beyond the
existing physics or chemistry knowledge.
Right.
So there is no clear answer.
That that
I I guess we can go
further than that
that just you know taking advantage of
the intuition but also if there is a
existing first the principle
Schrodinger equations for example then
if you can incorporate that into the
neural net model that would be wonderful
you know.
Yeah the incorporation of the hard
physical restraints uh
is
always beneficial.
Yeah.
All right. Sounds good. Is there any
other questions from audience like I
don't see it from chat room but you can
unmute yourself and ask directly.
Yeah we can chat so
What?
I guess no.
Well let's thank our speaker Sergey for
the wonderful talk today. Um
Okay. Thank you so much for attending
and thank you hopefully sort of like it
wasn't so bad and if you have other
questions feel free to reach me and I
would be happy to answer or to hook you
up with other members of the team so
that
there is an endless sky is the limit to
interactions and collaborations.
Wonderful wonderful. Thank you so much
again for the wonderful talk Sergey. Um
Okay let me just stop button for the
recording.